[Music]
hi everyone my name's Nate and I'm here
from the web you team and I'd like to
talk about some modern webview best
practices or as I like to call it using
webview like it's 2018 because it is so
before I dive into what's modern with
webview let's talk a little bit about
what's old
so web views been around since the very
beginning it was added back in API level
1 and it changed in a significant way
starting with lollipop it became
updatable the implementation was and
this is great because it meant that
users could benefit from security fixes
and bug fixes in an update every six
weeks just like your browser but a lot
has changed since then too
we've added 40 new api's just to make it
easier to work with webview to help
developers okay but what's really
changed well when we look out at the
ecosystem it seems like apps are kind of
using webview the same way they've
always used it and you know when you
look at sec overflow the answers are
outdated at best they certainly aren't
best practices and often times they're
just wrong but some of the blame is on
our shoulders to our API Doc's are
written like it's still API level 1 and
you know everything has changed since
then so something that we did is we
looked over the past year and we looked
at at the Android ecosystem and we
looked at the devices that are out there
today
and what we found is that although we
added you know for example a new gate we
added all these great api's a lot of
apps can't really take advantage of them
because they only run on the nougat
devices and that's less than 50% of
devices today and has been over two
years since it came out but what we also
saw is that almost 90% of devices are
running lollipop which means that
they're taking webview updates and it
means that this webview implementation
on the device actually implements all
these new api's they just aren't exposed
on older platform levels so we thought
can we do better
so over the past year we've worked on
our Android X library we launched a new
Android X library and we're pretty
excited about it and the basic idea is
that we're gonna bring all these brand
new developer api's but we're gonna try
to give you the device coverage you need
and we're gonna support lollipop and
above we're gonna do this by leveraging
webbie's update cycle but we also spent
a lot of time on this library to make
sure it's really usable that you can
actually use these api's to do
productive things so we designed them to
be fairly straightforward to swap out
from the frameworks api's alright so
this all sounds fine but how can we
actually use this to make your apps
better so let's take an example since
the very beginning of android we've
given apps a lot of power to customize
web views behavior and in particular we
added a callback called should override
URL loading and the idea behind this
callback is that you can choose to for
Souderton navigations you know cancel
these in the webview and dispatch them
to a different app instead as an Android
intent so the example is you might have
a YouTube URL but that might be better
suited in the YouTube app and this
sounds great a lot of apps took
advantage of this actually but there's a
problem with the API we didn't get it
right the first time
the issues that JavaScript can trigger
navigations and what we found is that
there's some malicious JavaScript out in
the wild which actually tries to exploit
this app behavior and from the user's
perspective they might be reading some
web content and all of a sudden without
necessarily written it starts opening up
some new Android app that they're not
trying to open so we actually already
fixed this issue we fix this back in
nougat where the idea is we expose this
notion of user gesture did the user
actually trigger this navigation and it
actually works really really well but it
only works on these nougat and above
devices and these before nougat devices
are still vulnerable so we thought this
was a great candidate for Android X
library the idea is we're going to
expose this user gesture organ
all the way back to lollipop and this
means that you get this device coverage
for all these devices and you can
provide the safe experience to your
users but we also made sure that this
would be really easy for apps to
override there'd be no confusion so I
think we succeeded but let's take a look
at the code
so before nougat here's kind of what our
code what a lot of apps code might have
looked like we're overriding should
override URL loading we're setting at
webview clients and you know in the body
of this we might be dispatching intents
and this is the insecure version of the
API but back in those days this is the
best we could do some of the better apps
out there and when nougat was released
might it have something like this so
you're overriding the old implementation
from before and this is for those before
nougat devices but for the new devices
you have this new implementation and
we're checking user gesture and we're
not launching intent if we have the if
we don't have user gesture so this seems
great but you know it only runs on a
small number of devices even today only
50% so here's how it looks with Android
X and the first thing I want to point
out is that almost nothing changed on
this slide I think that's really
beautiful it means all the code that you
already wrote to handle you know the old
framework API is that codes all the same
the only difference here is that we're
employee we're importing our web you
client compact class from our Android X
library and we're setting this compact
client and the idea here is that when
you're using the compact client all
these callbacks will get instead of only
invoked on nougat and above they'll
actually get invoked all the way back to
lollipop so you're going to get the
device coverage you need to provide your
users a safer experience without really
changing a whole lot of code this is
just one example of what we have to
offer in Android X so I'd really like to
encourage you to go check it out and see
how this can help you make your app
better you know we're giving you the
device coverage you need to actually use
these api's but we're gonna have a lot
more api's available some of these are
going to be small improvements on
classic api's like we've seen but some
are gonna be for entirely new features
like Safe Browsing and the best part is
that this isn't some soon-to-be-released
library this is already out there you
can go home you can add this into your
apps and it's ready to go so you can try
it our 1.0 release now like to take a
minute and shift gears a little bit so
we've kind of looked at the Android XA P
eyes and these seem great you're gonna
give us new AP eyes with you know pretty
good device coverage we almost 90% but
what about these AP eyes that have been
around forever
these have 100% device coverage but some
of them are kind of hard to use even I
struggle to use them correctly and I
work on the team so a common use case
that we've seen is loading in-app
content and the idea here is that you
want to display some content in your
application but you don't necessarily
want to fetch it over the internet you
want to just compile it right into your
app but you also want to continue to
build this content with web technology
you want to use HTML Javascript CSS and
what have you has had pretty good
support for this in fact we almost have
too much support for this we have so
many AP eyes that it's hard to figure
out which one is actually the right
thing to use and some of them have some
weird gotchas that make them kind of
hard to use so I thought maybe we could
take a look at some of these ap eyes and
talk about you know what's so tough
about them and recommend some best
practices you don't have to start from
scratch with a new API but you can kind
of tweak how you're using these so the
first API we can look at is load data
and the basic idea here is that this is
going to accept some HTML contact it
accepts it as a string and it's supposed
to display this in the webview but one
of the gotchas is it doesn't really
accept HTML content it accepts encoded
HTML content
the idea is you need to escape some
special characters you replace them with
a % and you know code following it and
we call this percent encoding and this
is the default configuration for the API
but there's actually no framework API to
do the percent-encoding for you it's
kind of an oversight but the end result
is that developers what we've seen is
that developers tend to actually do this
percent encoding by hand themselves and
this is manual it leads to bugs and
these bugs can have significant impacts
for your application you know one small
bug might seem okay today but it might
break in a future webview update if you
forget to encode a particular character
the other issue with load data is this
thing called an opaque origin so your
content gets loaded has what we call an
opaque origin and this means that it's
going to fail all same origin checks in
the web and these same origin checks are
actually critical to providing powerful
web api's securely without these same
origin checks you can't use great api's
like xml httprequest so what can we do
with this API well first off we can
actually escape some of these encoding
related problems it turns out this API
has always accepted an alternate
encoding scheme called base64 and this
actually isn't that special of an
encoding scheme is just a different
scheme it's not necessarily better but
it's kind of nice because there's
actually a framework API which will do
the encoding for you and it does it
correctly great this is basic C for dot
encode to string this will take the
content and spit out the right answer
and frankly the only reason it's not
documented is because this came out in
API level 8 which today is ancient
history but was still in the future at
the time of writing load data but we can
also take a look at these same origin
restrictions so the way we recommend to
get around this is to use something
called load data with base URL and one
of the nice things about this I think of
as a feature not a bug is that it
actually accepts content as is you can
actually give it content that's even
totally unencoded you don't even have to
worry about the base64 stuff
if you use this API the other really
nice thing about it is that it has this
thing called a base URL and although
you're displaying this HTML content you
pass in as a string the base URL kind of
configures this origin that it operates
with so you can control which origin you
get without disabling important security
settings just to make api's work so how
do we actually choose the right base URL
so this is something that even I
struggle with when I try to use this API
I know it's the right thing but I
actually don't know what the right thing
is to pass to it so I actually thought
how about we go through some of the
common use cases so something that we've
seen is that a lot of apps use cached
content this is content they may have
downloaded from the web over the
Internet's but they're saving it for
later and now when they show it then
need to show with the right base URL and
the right URL D choose is just the
original URL that it came from this
guarantees that you know if it worked
originally it's going to have the same
exact origin and all the api's are going
to continue to work the other use case
that we've noticed is that apps tend to
ship their own content and display it
this way which is great what we
recommend is that you choose a real
internet type URL under these HTTPS or
HTTP URLs and it should use your
organization's real domain and the
reason for this is that you can import
other resources from your servers and
use them in this content without
worrying about any same origin checks
it'll all work and then there's the
question of what do we use HTTPS or HTTP
so here's a little rule of thumb and we
always want to encourage you to HTTPS is
the secure protocol but if you do need
to show insecure sources in secure
resources we'd recommend they use the
HTTP scheme as opposed to disabling
important security settings just to get
your app working and as the last point I
want to urge apps to avoid custom URL
schemes so this is something that we've
noticed is crop
apps will kind of make up their own
scheme and use that but the problem with
this is that the web standards don't
really expect custom URL schemes they're
very vague about how to handle this and
it turns out that they wind up getting
handled very inconsistent lis and this
can lead to surprising app breakage so
if you can stick to one of the internet
URL schemes you're gonna have a much
better time so hopefully I've kind of
expressed that we really do care about
developers at the web view team and
we're trying very hard to make sure that
you have powerful api's that have the
device covers you need while also paying
attention to some of these old api's and
making sure that we explain how these
needs to be used making sure that
they're actually usable if you have any
questions me and my colleagues will be
around for the rest of today as well as
tomorrow it would be more than happy to
talk to you about whether usage and you
know what you need for your application
thank you very much
[Music]